oh right I don't think this is going to
be like that for 20 years I have a
question no I have a rhetorical question
for the group here yeah this is an
interesting one so
there's no freebies in politics if you
do something you're getting rewarded or
you're going to pay a price people don't
do things for politicians out of the
goodness of their heart every single
radio and television ad for Gavin Newsom
for the last two months was tagged that
it was presented by Reed Hastings the
money that Reid Hastings spent ran the
media campaign for Gavin Newsom and it
was mentioned at the end of every spot
where they accused uh Larry Elder of
being right of trump being an
anti-vaxxer read Hastings read Hastings
read Hastings
does that come back now because of this
this race the streaming Wars does he get
an advantage
things yeah I know he's the CEO of
Netflix I don't think most people know
that he already has Susan Rice and
Morocco and Michelle Obama is bored so I
mean look it is what it is here's here
was really honest to God looking at this
my biggest takeaway San Francisco runs
the United States now it's not New York
it's not L.A it's not even DC the whole
United States runs through Silicon
Valley now and Silicon Valley runs
through San Francisco everything goes
through San Fran because of the media
social media
the politicians are are so in bed with
big Tech and big Tech is in San
Francisco and you think about it you've
got Gavin Newsom Dianne Feinstein
Barbara Baxter you've got Kamala Harris
uh Nancy Pelosi all of them San
Francisco residents right and you're
coming out Google Facebook every tech
company in in America has their their
Hub their their Hub where now why does
that scare me because this is going to
translate into into General Millie who
runs Silicon Valley
who who's running Silicon Valley right
now do you think who has more say over
what Google does America DC or Beijing
who dictates what Facebook does today DC
or Beijing
so if Silicon Valley is now the power
hub the information center of America
okay
and Silicon Valley doesn't answer to DC
it answers to Beijing who's running the
information unpack that why are you
saying that they all answer to Beijing
you're saying all these big tech
companies are all answering to
absolutely CCP which which companies
they will change their their their rules
they will change what they do which
companies all of them if you've been
tracking this at all for five years
every single update that they do every
single thing that they do and you're
talking about Hollywood we talk about
Hollywood the southern part of the state
John Cena are they are they changing
their movies to make sure that they
don't piss off conservative Americans or
libertarian Americans or independent
Americans or even Democrats so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]